hallo mein name ist ein kollege und ich
bin aufgestanden ist mein erster block
und ich zeige euch mal was ich heute
mache
lukas gab in der uni und ich mache mich
jetzt erst mal schick für ihn ich er ich
hoffe der akku reicht von der kamera
ich bin jetzt in der stadt angekommen
und geht es war zum pisa fall meine
haare sind schon ultra lang geworden
guten tag was machen wir heute schönes
meine haare müssen stück kürzer
ist gut so
jetzt sehe ich ob wir wieder raus wie
ökologie das macht dann sechs euro bitte
nein das ist aber zu wenig
was machen sie da ja
behindertenparkplatz das für teuer
wenn wir das nicht anders regeln ich
glaube nicht
wir lassen das fahrzeug gleich
abschleppen kleiner [ __ ]
euro
fal
hallo toll ist der akku leer
das war's mit oldies blog mich an
einfach waren angeschrieben der schon
mal culina video gemacht hat was ich
euch hier immer verlinke irgendwo da
könnt ihr mal hin klicken er malt er hat
eine ganz gute idee wie man vielleicht
das ökologie machen kann und dann hatte
diesen blog auf die beine gestellt und
wir haben auch ultrabook noch einen
zweiten teil vielleicht zu machen so
dass kollege vielleicht noch mal
irgendwie durch die stadt läuft und
vielleicht andere sachen erlebt und
vielleicht auch noch andere öko leder
dann trifft und so wenn ihr bock auf
noch einen zweiten block hat oder noch
ein dritter und ein vierter richtig mit
story und sodann schreibt das gerne in
die kommentare lassen bewertung da sein
kann alles unter der beschreibung von
link klicken sie darauf in denen uns